this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsay show where america
hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm john
deloney joined here by best-selling
author and good friend
anthony o'neil for taking your calls on
anything
on everything life money parenting
relationships school how to pay off your
student loans
everything give us a shout right away
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight
eight two five five two two five anthony
i haven't seen you in a while man how we
been and that's a good thing man that
means we've both been working
if we see too much of each other i mean
we're not working
i never thought of that i guess if
you're hanging out in the office that
means
we ain't doing that we ain't building
nothing i love it we're called it build
stuff
make stuff happen so what are you been
working on uh man a lot of things man uh
getting ready to go to two shows on uh
on my shoulder table with anthony o'neil
um working on uh getting ready for a
book next year to come out next fall so
i'm really excited about that
and uh just really working on a lot of
fun things that i really can't say just
yet
but um the key thing is really working
on myself
improving myself so i could be so i
could better serve the people
in america and our listeners that's
awesome well i hate the only time i get
to see you is
when i ain't working well yeah yeah
we're when dave's out of town but man
it's good to see you
all right let's get right to the phones
let's go to
mitchell across the pond mitchell how
are we doing
hi i'm doing fine thank you how are you
two outstanding man thanks for giving us
a shout so what's up how can we help
um so i'm 20 years old and i'm going to
university later this year
and i'm going to study law but last year
i managed to get into about 11 000
pounds worth of debt
and so now i'm working like 90 hours a
week basically
85 hours a week trying to pay it off and
but it feels like i'm
burning out it's working in a factory so
it's not sitting down 12 hour shifts
basically every day and and yeah no i
just
i don't know what to do so i call in and
ask you guys
yeah that's good man uh i love it i love
it so 11 11
11 pounds is about what 15k here in
america
yeah that's right yeah about about 15 15
five so
um now let me answer this question are
you are you still in school
as far as in how much longer do you have
to go
and so i'd be starting i'd be starting
my first year so
i i've been doing i've been doing one
year at the open university
by going to an like an in-person
university yep and so uh that's why i'm
starting
yeah okay cool great so here here's the
thing what i really want you to do
and focus on uh mitchell don't worry
about the debt right now okay what i
want you to do is how do we get a game
plan
that can help you not rack up any more
debt moving forward
because what we don't want to do is
continue stocking uh
the powell of debt over here how do we
prevent you from borrowing
more money from moving forward so do you
have a
job do you have well you do have a job i
mean how much money are you making
a month right now um
so a month i'm making well i've got a
job but i've also got a cleaning company
so i've got people that do cleaning
for me so i bring in about four and a
half four and a half grand
a month okay and roughly forty five
hundred dollars a month okay how much is
going to cost you a semester to go to
school
uh it's costing uh it's a semester half
a year
yeah half a year how much uh four and a
half
four and a half okay cool so that means
you can cash flow college then am i
correct
uh i i mean not really because it's
because at the moment the job i'm doing
is working in a factory in the south so
i'm in brighton but the university i'm
going to is in new york okay
and up north so i wouldn't be able to do
the work that i'm doing now once i go
okay so we got to figure out what are we
going to do here because the thing is
i'm not going to tell you take out any
student loans or borrow any more money
so we need to figure out how can you
work
in cash flow school or another option
which is not a popular option john is is
this is this the right school for you to
go to
that is this school yeah within your
budget that's the question
this the school is um the reason one of
the reasons we're going there is because
i i didn't get any real qualifications
from senior school which you know your
high school
or college so i've i've got in basically
on the basis of my experience and
um personal statement so
well in all that's well and good right
but if you can't afford it you can't
afford it
right man why are you choosing you've
got a cleaning company you're
working hard in a factory what is it
about the university that
is calling your name why do you want to
quit your your small business why do you
want to quit
your day job so the green business will
carry on but
the job that i've got basically i got to
pay off the debt it's just like anything
i used to work in an insurance company
before this okay
and but i i had to leave because they
sold
that part of the business and but the
reason i want to go is because it's it's
in the russell good so
it's one of the top schools over here
and it's and it's doing law so obviously
there's that
future career there that potentially
guarantees that's more valuable than
the cleaning business that i've got yeah
but i'm not i'm not concerned john about
the the value or
what people say is one of the best
schools what's the school that you can
afford bro
that's the conversation we need to have
not what's the best school
that magazines are saying or that the
community is saying there in england
what's the school that you can afford
because if you can just get the
education of what you
need you will come out on top all right
so if you're making forty five hundred
dollars a month in american money it's
going to cost you forty five hundred
dollars a semester
um it sounds like you can cash flows
from school
but you may need to go to a cheaper
school so that way you could be better
off in the long run
or some law schools don't let you work
while you're attending right so you may
have to take a year or two
will they let you um postpone your
entrance
um i think i'm past that point now so
it's a case of
i have to go i i have been approved for
student loans here
but i know you guys like that yeah you
know we don't do that brother not even
in england
beautiful place to be but not not with
student loans well just
listen to the the situation you're you
called about and that you're putting
yourself in
okay yeah you found yourself
fifteen thousand eleven thousand pounds
in debt fifteen thousand dollars in debt
and you're having to work in a factory
eighty five ninety hours a week to pay
it off yeah that's rough
and your solution your next step is to
go
get into more debt that you're going to
have to find yourself whether it's in a
factory
or i was the dean of students at a law
school man
and my law students would sometimes get
themselves so underwater
student loans that they had to take jobs
at law practices that they
didn't agree with they didn't love that
required 100 hours a week from them
they just took their souls from them to
pay off these student loans
does that make sense you're putting
yourself in that same situation
yeah so the student loans here the way
it works is you don't pay you don't pay
a penny unless you earn over 27 grand
okay and after that you pay you start
paying this a certain percentage there's
no pressure on you it's not like a
regular payment they write it off after
30 years if you don't pay
but i'm hoping to move to the states to
carry on with the actual law career
so it's likely that i'm would get
written off if that makes sense
that income wouldn't be eligible to be
taken because it's not run through
the uk yeah mitchell we're not going to
play with that man okay
here here's the thing don't even touch
it we don't play the what if or there's
a possibility
we play the what can i control you can
control by not taking out the student
loans
you can control by choosing a cheaper
and more affordable school
or possibly delaying school until you
cash flow bottom line
yeah i don't i don't know how england
does student loans
right i just want to live by a rule i'm
not going to trust the government to
take care of me
when i owe them money absolutely
but i like england i love it this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
um
this is the ramsey show give us a shout
at triple eight eight two five five
two two five i'm john deloney joined
here by best-selling author and youtube
sensation anthony o'neil
checking your calls on life on money
let's go to samantha in jordan utah
what's up samantha how are we doing
hey anthony hey dave it's great to talk
to you guys
i'm john i wish i was dave he's way
better looking than me
both physically and bank account wise no
hey it's all good
no i'm sorry that's funny
yeah so it's really it's really great
that both of you guys are on the line
today i've been meaning to try to talk
to
john since he's been a member
since like uh 2020 and anthony i'm such
a huge fan of yours
you're a millennial like i am and it's
great what you're doing for
millennials and helping them get our
debt for student loans um
john um this question is mainly for you
today
i have recently discovered that my
father
has stage four lung cancer and um
it was a shock to everyone just because
he
went in for like just a regular
procedure
he had a tumor on his adrenal glands
and we were just told well 90 of them
were benign so
it should be just a quick you know in
and out 48 hours you know stay maybe
and it turned out it was a lot more
in depth and ever since he got out of
surgery from that
thing that has been one after another
like he's been through blood clots he's
been through
so many things he just barely got out of
the hospital
on tuesday and um
i haven't been able to see him you know
since uh
like almost two weeks now because i
wasn't able to go visit him in the
hospital because of the
um the kelvin restrictions yeah i think
i think
maybe also because he was in the icu i
understand that they want to limit
people
sure from you know spreading germs and
stuff in the
icu but so how can i yeah so
i i want to know
what i can do to prepare myself
to accept this um
i think that i have tried i've grieved
um i learned i've learned a lot about
grieving
um that you know even if you don't lose
someone
their lives are never going to be the
same and your life is never going to be
the same if they're close to you like a
family member
and so i'm trying to prepare myself as
much as i can to say okay well
my dad's dying he's gonna die from this
probably sooner rather than
rather than later yep um so hey dude
do this for me samantha don't spend your
energy
trying to prepare yourself spend your
energy being with your dad
that's good right spend your energy
letting him know
that he did a good job that you love him
that he's got a will
that he's got his end end game wrapped
up
the last thing on earth you want to do
is start building protective walls and
putting up shields
and protecting yourself from pain
because that pain is going to find its
way in and out of your heart
some shape form or fashion right and so
trying to defend yourself from hurting
because your dad
was suddenly given a a just a brutal
cancer
cancer diagnosis that nobody saw coming
that's a futile exercise it's an
exercise in
hyper anxiety and depression and coming
out all over the place
okay so instead of doing that i want you
to actually get some people around you
that you love and you trust and i want
you to sit down and just
feel this hurt it should hurt real bad
yeah because it sucks and i definitely
have i've you know i have some great
people in my life and i'm grateful
that i do because you know like
it's a true testament to the people
around you when something
you know bad happens because it's always
easy to be around people when good stuff
is happening but when bad stuff
happens that's right that's when you
really understand who your real
you know people are in your life that's
right so i want you to here's what i
want you to do i want you to
make sure you are around those folks
i want you to even reach out to two or
three of them and say hey y'all you're
my go-to's
in the middle of the night in the
afternoon if i text you and say i need
to talk i want you to commit to stepping
outside of whatever meeting you're in
and hollering at me
if i need you to come over and pick
something up or
get a couple of rider dies with you and
that's going to allow you to drop your
shoulders
and just experience this for what it is
it's a miserable awful
thing and then i want you to be around
your dad as
much as it's safe as as possible
make sure you can write him a letter
that he can read over and over and over
and tell him that you love him
and you are so grateful to have been on
this ride with him
and don't start writing him off yet old
dads are tough man he
um man he may come through this and
things may be okay and if it's not stage
four lung cancer is tough right
um it's a hard way to go it's it's it's
devastating for your whole family
don't try to wall up and be hardcore and
tough
man it doesn't help or benefit anybody
or anything this is gonna be a hard
season for your family
let him know you love him let your mom
know you love him let your family know
you love them and make sure you reach
out to
um let others know when you need help
right
anthony have you experienced i know you
you haven't lost parents but
how how do you experience grief and
wrestle with grief
you know i just lost my uh one of my
closest cousins
uh i'm sorry a couple of months ago and
it was actually february 11th uh we lost
her
and i mean it was hard
you know it was hard but you know i
i'm a christian so while while i'm while
i'm
grieving i'm also a part of me is also
celebrated
celebrating
that this individual is in a better
place i wish
i wish my cousin was still here with
with our family with her
siblings with her mom and dad she wasn't
married she didn't have any kids
but i've learned throughout grieving be
honest with my pain
to be true with myself but then also
just step back and understand
with the faith that i practice she's in
a better place
than uh this uh world today with a lot
going on
she's in a much better place and so for
me man i just learned to be honest
be there for the family be there for my
loved ones um allow
allow tears allow pain allow questions
uh i don't have the answers um i'm just
taking it one step at a time and we're
still processing this as a family man
just the other week
i broke down emotional because i drove
into atlanta where she was
and uh when i soon got into atlanta i
just thought about that and i literally
allowed myself to cry for 30 minutes
good for you
you know because it's like i'm a grown
man but at the same time
i have emotions i have feelings and but
but tears
are healing tears help you process
and so for me when i'm grieving i allow
myself to be emotional and i allow
myself to feel the pain
uh but then also i encourage myself
during that same process
so you just did something that i think
um i don't want to blow by it man which
i think it's really important to point
out
it was a both and for you which is i'm
gonna
feel this stuff i'm gonna acknowledge
the stuff and
i'm gonna get up and go do what i need
to do yeah absolutely it's at both end i
am going to go visit people i am going
to see people
i am going to like you talked about
before the break
i'm going to keep working yeah right if
i've got the capacity to do that
and if i got to pull over the side of
the road and pull over inside the road
absolutely and i find folks
do one or the other right and samantha
here i'm i'm grateful that she was brave
to call
they want to wrap themselves up in an
armor not feel it
right i'm just gonna get back to it and
do it or man people
just shut it down yeah right and they
don't reach out and they don't
and it's hard man when grief looks
different for everybody we try to make
people grieve all the same way
or start comparing grief man that
destroys relationships and destroys
people make people feel nuts
right yeah man if you tell somebody hey
you got to do it like this yeah right
good for you man sorry to hear about
your cousin all right man it's all good
she's in a better place appreciate the
the thoughts you know um our family is
taking it one step at a time and
you know what was so funny is uh after
the funeral
i was i was february 14th i'm coming
home
and i got into a car accident yeah i
remember that i thought i was about to
die
and when i got back to the hotel room
john i just started crying even more
yeah and i said i'm just gonna cry i
have no answer for this i'm just gonna
cry cry cry
next morning i woke up let nothing
happen you feel you feel 25 pounds
lighter huh
so much lighter thanks for sharing i
wasn't trying to be a man i was just
trying to be an emotional man at the
time
trying to be a human being is that right
yeah and we've had a lot of loss this
last year
feel it get people around you don't
pretend feelings aren't real cause they
are
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsay show i'm john
delonia joined here by best-selling
author
and all-around great guy anthony o'neil
we're taking your calls on life and
money
let's go to dan in champaign illinois
dan
what is going on hey good afternoon
thank you for taking my call
you got it man what's up how can we help
well we uh have been working ken's
proximity principle
uh the framework that we put out there
that you guys put out there and it
worked a little faster than we expected
actually
that's that's kind of yeah that's kind
of what we're calling about here i want
to give you a little bit of background
and then i was hoping for maybe a 3000
foot view and a little unbiased opinion
you got it all right so a little
background my wife and i are on baby
step seven
uh we currently are making about 135 140
a year between both of our jobs
and i run a small side business okay
we're
working at a family but so far that's
not happening so it's just the two of us
at the moment
basically the job is out of state and
we're looking at a pretty big move if
we're going to do this
and in order to do this move uh the job
that was offered to her
um was about three thousand dollars less
than
what she currently makes um which
they've given us a pretty good ladder
and whatnot
but we are a little nervous about the
fact that i've got to find a job down
there as well
et cetera et cetera essentially what my
question is
is with a couple of our contacts that we
use for the proximity principle
one of them has moved away we're afraid
that
if we don't do this because of the
salary and some of the family things
that are going on that would burn a
bunch of bridges
uh between the contact as well as the
company
uh as well as you know ruin some of the
gym growth that we finally started
seeing since covenant shut us down for
so long
that's my my side business yeah so we're
just kind of stuck as to whether we
should take this job or not
hmm well man thank you for walking that
through man
um long story short i've been in this
situation multiple times
with me and my wife um she was a
professor i was a
higher ed geek and a lot of times you
take a job you got to move to a new town
someone's got to wrap up their semester
or their year and so we've been through
this several times
so here's what i'll tell you um other
you can't make a decision that's not
good for you and your wife
because somebody else might get mad at
y'all
does that make sense at the end of the
day
you guys walk down a road with somebody
and
what was ultimately put on that they
ultimately put on the table
wasn't good for your family and maybe
another fifty thousand dollars would
have helped maybe the
wrong timing whatever the thing is
that's between you and your wife and
they don't get a vote
period if you're going to move to
different states different cities i can
tell you on my own experience
is you got to have a really detailed
communication plan between the two of
you it's got to have a deadline on it
and you have to be really hyper
intentional with one another
it's real easy to get into your own
rhythm in another town or another city
and all of a sudden you look up and
you've you've got a you've got a
roommate that doesn't even live with you
anymore
right and then you gotta re-learn how to
be connected why
why why do you why does she want to have
a different job are you guys looking
why are you working the proximity
principle as millionaires
looking to get out of where you are well
not quite millionaire status yet
okay we're getting there uh houses paid
for and what not uh as far as why
a couple main reasons uh one we kind of
fell in love with the uh the area we're
looking at the southeast
tennessee area so uh mountains you know
better tax climate for my business if i
were to reopen it there
uh i wouldn't get shut down near as long
and then um
i am not a big fan of the winter so i'm
looking forward to getting into some
warmer weather
okay uh so that would be kind of the the
main
issues there and then as far as why this
company why
why this uh sort of role
it's essentially a lateral move she's
already doing this project manager work
but it would be you know a foot in the
door and a job offer
in in the area that we both want to live
eventually so why don't you just do it
how old are you how old are you uh we
are 34.
um i want you to do it what are you
going to lose
hey the damn
thing that i'm i'm worried about losing
sorry i didn't mean to cut you off there
anthony would be
uh the the job uh that i currently have
is bringing in about 70. yeah so i'd be
going down
quite a bit in salary if i if i find a
role there
and then you know with with everything
you know the seeing things kind of
starting back into
into the normal routine with the with
the gym
we're a little nervous about just all of
them being like we'll see you later so
i'll turn it over to anthony but i'll
leave you with this
the reason you do all that work to get
out of debt
so you can do whatever you want wherever
you want it
the reason you work so hard to get out
of debt to get connected with your wife
is so that y'all can pack up a move
wherever you want to some weird mountain
town in the middle of nowhere and take a
giant pay cut it doesn't hurt you
and you'll get to do what you want
that's just my opinion on it anthony
hop in here yeah i mean i agree with you
john i mean you work the baby steps so
you can have options and you can have
freedom
um i don't know if i would take a
massive pay cut
but you know but i i would if if i know
i want to be in this state this is where
me and my wife
want to settle down at i would i would
consider a
pay cut to eventually get back to where
i was to possibly making more money
uh but i'm curious i can't remember off
the top of my head does illinois have
state tax
oh yeah yes sir cool so is that three
thousand dollars a year you're losing
out on
or three thousand dollars a month your
wife would be losing out on
so my wife would be losing that on three
thousand a year which is not
the the concern it's more of the you
know i'd probably be taking a thirty or
forty thousand dollar paid cut just to
get my foot in the door somewhere
down there cool and then so
coming back to no no state tax here in
the state of tennessee
you know it wouldn't be that that you
make that up yeah you'll make that up
maybe not 30 grand but you'll make up
another 10
my another 10 grand um and so
i'm like i'm like john here you know i'm
having a conversation with my wife and
i'm asking my wife this
what do we want to do long term where do
we want to be long term do we want to be
in tennessee in the next five years
if that is our end goal then okay cool
is this the best avenue of getting us to
that goal
and before we make a decision over here
we're going to pursue two or three other
things
you're going to look for another job dan
and see if we can find some different
options to where
instead if we're losing out on 30 grand
i may lose out on
10 grand maybe lose out on 15 grand and
then you'll make
some of that back up um within not
having
to say tax here now your wife is going
to make she's not it's going to be a
lateral move
and she may even make a little bit more
money because she doesn't have to stay
taxed
so right now from you i'm looking at one
what's the best move for the family
and if the family is saying yes we want
to be here
how can we do this the right way and
with you being debt free having a fully
funded emergency fund and even having a
paid for a home
you're in a position to where you can
lose a little bit i just want to make
sure that when you move
you will or you can lose but what do you
gain long term and again it's not all
money the gain is
life life it is freedom it is it is the
options it is the choice that we want
the school district that we want to be
in you know the home that we want the
people the community
the state you can't get any better than
the state of tennessee i'm gonna tell
you that right
now all right you just can't i don't
know why people still living in
california just come on over here
to the state of tennessee you know i
think we're full up brother actually
i know we are you know it's a lot but
you know
that's what i would say to you dan it's
just to
you know um step back and just get get
it get it have a dream meeting
with your wife yeah and just just dream
together okay what's our dream
is it tennessee or is it florida or is
it another state whatever that is have a
dream meeting
and then define okay what does it look
like for us to get there
um and then from there your answer your
answer will be there
dan just this is mrs my personal life
there was a season when i wasn't well i
left my wife and i
left a university we took a 70 000
household income pay cut
because it was the right thing for our
family and our little kid
and within short order we'd circled back
up and i picked up extra stuff i got my
head screwed on straight i got the help
that i needed my wife
ended up with another the money has
taken care of itself
in ways we could have never imagined
because we looked at what anthony did
where do we actually want to be where do
you want to be with our family what do
you want this thing to look like
what does it take for us to be whole as
a group and then
man you and your wife have worked the
plans your baby steps seven
she's making great money you're an
entrepreneur making great money dude i'm
not worried about the money part i want
you and your wife
to go build an adventure together and go
figure it out
and you're 34. no decision you make is
forever none
this is a bust go back to illinois in a
couple of years y'all figure it out
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
listen there is a better tomorrow
waiting for you this is your chance to
learn how to make faster and real
progress with your money and your
personal goals when you check out our
world
international intergalactic famous 10
book sale at ramsey solutions you can
pick up my new quick read redefining
anxiety
for only 10 bucks to learn what anxiety
is what it's
not and how to get your life back or
anthony o'neill's newly designed
book the graduate survival guide for
also for only 10 bucks
anthony's got several best-selling books
in there our life-changing books are 60
off for only a few more weeks there's
something for everybody
this is your chance hey we stumbled
and tripped and fell through this school
year which wrapping up
as we head into the summer let's change
our lives for the better
right this is your chance to stay six
save sixty percent off and
get a gift of best of our best-selling
books
shop our ten dollar sale at the online
store at ramseysolutions.com
all right let's go to michaela in omaha
nebraska michaela what's up how are you
doing
hi thank you so much for letting me call
in i'm doing okay how are you
we are doing great we're doing great how
can we help
well so i'm recently a single mom
and my daughter's special needs and i'm
in the last year of my graduate program
i own a home
and i am financially struggling i work
in the service industry
so and my daughter because of her
special needs she's been removed from
several daycares
so i've had a hard time keeping
employment through that
i haven't reached out for any handouts
or subsidies
or and i don't even know where to start
with that but as far as finances go
i'm in the middle of this debate of
whether or not to sell my house
which there's about seventy thousand
dollars in equity there
or so in cash out and rent or to take
a line of credit on my home just in
order to survive the next year
to get through school so how come you
are a
new single mom what happened
uh well i was in a relationship with
domestic violence
and i chose to gosh i don't want to get
emotional but i chose to
make a better choice for my daughter and
i it's good for you
good question so how much are you making
right now i mean
do you have any income i i do have stem
income i work my
ass upstairs my butt off at a golf
course
um and i make roughly around 1600
a month and that's before child support
so
and that's what i'm able to bring in at
this point what's your grad school
program
i i want to be a clinical mental health
therapist
very cool okay all right all right all
right and
uh this is important right now this is
something you have to do
right now right now you know honestly
i've already pushed it out a couple
times before i'm
ten thousand dollars and get to the
school program
and this is something that's important
for me to finish because i know it's
going to be able to
allow me to work at the
amount that i'm going to need to bring
in for my daughter and i
want to be a single mom i thought i need
to have my master's degree in this
how much is going to cost you to finish
one more year
um well that that's kind of that's the
hard thing right now is that it's
already costing me ten thousand dollars
in student loans and then
to finish the programs one more year
it's going to be about another five
grand in student loans
so you only need five thousand dollars
to finish off this year
i need five thousand dollars to finish
off just school but that is without
eating or skin child care and keeping a
roof over my head
yeah we need my daughter's head yeah we
need we need we need to figure figure
something else out five thousand dollars
i get it
is a lot of money but then on the flip
side is is not a lot of money and it's
not worth you selling your home
and especially not taking out a heloc on
your home
um and so under no circumstances do you
take out heloc ever ever ever yeah and
then
especially i don't care how hard you're
working your butt off
not taking out any any private loans or
anything but we need to figure out how
can we
work smart not just work
hard okay so you're saying you're making
sixteen hundred dollars a month
where are you living in our house yeah
well i'm living in
omaha nebraska and the sixteen hundred
dollars is
it is subject to change um come
september because that's when my program
changes
into an internship and i might be only
able to work
you know one maybe two days a week
because it's very rigorous and i'm going
to be working in clinic with patients
when i say where you're living as far as
i should have said how much is your
mortgage
oh sorry i'm so sorry
it's a thousand dollars a month okay and
how much does your child support check
900. okay so that's on top of the
sixteen hundred dollars that you're
getting
okay yeah all right so we are
um okay so we're at about twenty five
hundred dollars a month
okay and you're saying you're do you
have any family in in
in the area that can help you out with
your child
no family in the area and the family i
do have has passed away
okay i'm so sorry about that um
here's the thing i want to figure out
how do we get this five grand
i mean and pay for it cash if you're
saying this is what you really need to
do to be more successful moving down
and it's going to give you the the the
opportunity to make more money
then i need to figure out how do we do
this selling your home
is not an option taking out a heloc loan
for five thousand dollars
is not an option taking out a heloc loan
for a hundred thousand
is not an option um taking out student
loans is not an option because here's
the thing you're gonna get comfortable
with it
you're already ten thousand dollars in
debt you're gonna add another five
thousand
that 15 000 would take you 20 years i
guarantee it
because of the circumstances that you're
in so i want to ask you a question do
you want to work hard for the next
year maybe six months to a year um
to get through the rest of this time
without racking up any more debt
or do you want to spend the next 20 30
years uh paying back
um all this stuff so for me i'm trying
to figure out
okay one how do i find uh
substantial help for my child two what
else can i pick up
just for six months to cash flow
this five thousand dollars that's the
question that i'm asking michaela i
picked up on something that i want to
can i since you called us can i poke and
pride on you for a second
oh yes of course yes i need help you you
mentioned
at the beginning you made sure to tell
america
that you don't take handouts you don't
take assistance
you're figuring this out yourself
if somebody was come in for you and talk
to you as their therapist and
you're in your exact situation
you would tell them what that you gotta
ask for help right
absolutely but you have to advocate for
yourself and you have to there we go
you have to get the help that's being
offered to you there you go so here's
what i want you to do
are you at unm right there i'm at you
and
oh yeah okay so um i worked at
at one of the sister schools there for
for several years here's what i want you
to do i want you to walk into your
program director
and say this is really hard for me to do
and it would be vulnerable here but
here's my situation
are there any scholarship dollars for
single mothers
are there because they'll hold them in
pockets
are there grants are there work i can do
here can i become a ga a grad assistant
and grade papers
and so that they will waive that last
five thousand dollars of tuition
when you get your job at your internship
that's when you're going to ask hey i
need to find one that's going to have a
paying placement
there or i want to help take on shifts
as a receptionist there
so i can pick up hours and double dip
and make money at the same time
but here all this here's the thing
here's what i want you to hear me the
global statement
there is some solutions here and it's
going to involve you
being vulnerable and honest and going
and asking for people to help you out
and that for you michaela is really hard
but i know this
you can do really hard stuff she's
already been doing it that's what i'm
saying
and you're worth it your kid's worth it
and you've been brave you left a
rough ugly messy disgusting situation
because you're worth it
and i want you to take that next step
and go ask you promise me you'll do it
so i promise thank you so much michaela
all of us the whole country's rooting
for you right now and when you get that
scholarship i want you to write me an
anthony don't let us know
and we're going to be cheering you on
you've got this and the clients that you
serve in the future
are going to be blessed because of the
road you've walked and the new road
you're gonna pay
it's one hour in the books this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm john deloney joined
here by best-selling author youtube star
anthony o'neill and we are taking your
calls on your money
your retirement your life your
relationships
anything and everything give us a call
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five
two two five the wonderful kelly
celebrating her ramsey bursary today
she's been here for a hundred and eleven
years and you look
good for a hundred and eleven year old i
need you to know that wow
wow that's actually it's like uh being
here she's been here nine years
but that's like in i'm not i was gonna
say it's like being here in dog years
you're not a dog i'm just saying
every year at ramsay is long right
she's been here for 176 years
screening your calls triple 825 5225
she'll answer the call here
and boy does she have a smile on her
face i was just about to say
if america could see what kelly is doing
right now
i don't think they would want to even
call in bro the glass the studio glass
is double-paned
for good reason so what i'm going to do
is bail myself out and go to nick
in scranton pennsylvania thank you
what's up nick how are you doing save us
nick
help us out brother how are you guys
doing we're doing great man
how are you i'm doing well i'm doing
well
so i'll give you guys a little bit of
background so i am 22 i just graduated
from college
congratulations and i start my first
full thank you i start my first
full-time position on monday
so you're about to be an old man
starting monday huh
yes sir congratulations so what's up
thank you
so i wanted to get some advice on how to
plan best for my
financial future and you know maybe try
to turn myself into an everyday
millionaire
outstanding i love it i love it how much
debt are you graduating with nick
so my parents do as much as they can but
i do have twenty thousand dollars in
federal student loans okay
anything else any cars credit cards no
nothing else okay cool so you got 20k
and uh student loans all right
and how much are you gonna be making a
year there
63 000 plus a five percent bonus sixty
thousand
hey at how old are you brother i'm 22.
no okay nick you got your woman brother
you you single
i have a girlfriend of three years and
we have been
talking about getting married recently
okay i'm sorry ladies nick
is taken all right nick what do you do
if what are you doing for a living
uh i'm i'm in finance so i'm working for
a large
german medical manufacturer okay and i
am in their finance
organization congratulations man so
here's the key thing nick
that i want to give you and america
listen
i'll talk about this on my shoulder
table with anthony o'neil and to any
millennials listening
especially in this nick age bracket if
you're in the 20s and the 30s head over
to youtube check out the show
anthony.com to learn more information
about that but
nick one of the greatest of um things i
can give you right now it's nothing
about money
okay but it helps you with money and
that is
the caliber of your financial future
will be determined upon the choices that
you make right now
and if if if you're being very
intentional about making the right
choice uh when it comes to your finances
when it comes to your life when it comes
to
what you're putting inside of your mind
that will eventually come out of your
heart and out of your mouth
and into this earth you will be
successfully financially
and so one of the things i really want
to encourage you to do is to step back
and
write down your why you know why do you
want to have the things that you're
doing you want to be a husband one day
you're dating this amazing young lady
you said and
y'all was talking about marriage well
what kind of husband do you want to be
what kind of provider to your home do
you want to be
if you if you desire kids what kind of
father do you want to be
what do you want to leave you know your
your family down the road what do you
want to build
when it comes to wealth when it comes to
dreams when it comes to
your legacy and so at your age
if i can go back to my age at 21 22 23
years old
that's the conversation that i'm having
before i have any other
money conversation where are you
going anthony what do you want to do
because if you can get a solid why nick
hear me clearly
a solid why then the price of commitment
is going to be
easier for you to do if your why doesn't
make you cry
then the price of commitment will so
that's number one is just make sure that
you're being very intentional
with the choices and the decisions
you're making
then number two nick is you gotta attack
this twenty thousand dollars
you gotta have the mindset of i am broke
yes i'm making sixty three thousand
dollars by the end of this first year
i'm gonna make about 70 with that 5k
bonus but you know what
you only make 20 000. you're broke okay
you are living way below your means
you got to tell your girlfriend i'm
sorry baby girl we can't go to red
lobster
we can't go to ruth chris steakhouse red
lobster you know
right now we can go to my house yo house
or to the picnic
and we're gonna have peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches we're gonna have
hot dogs tomatoes and white rice we're
gonna be drinking
all the water we can until we pay off
this twenty thousand dollars in debt and
it's not we as you
and you have that mindset for at least
one full year you're gonna pay off to
twenty thousand dollars
you're gonna set aside three to six
months and brother that means
you're 25 years old you're 100 debt free
you got a fully funded emergency fund
you have hopefully you'll be
either talking or engaged or married by
then
and the combined income is at six
figures in your 20s
now y'all investing and now y'all are
building wealth
and here's the thing man i did uh i have
a show coming out
[ __ ] i want you to check this out man
um i have a show coming out if you just
invest
500 uh 500 a month
you know which for you um your 15
of what we teach on babysit for it's
gonna be right around seven
eight hundred dollars a month that
you're going to be investing um
if you do that by the time you turn 55
you can have about 1.8 1.9 million
dollars sitting in your
in your retirement accounts that's just
off of right
simple investments you know yeah and can
i throw one more thing out here real
quick throw it to me brother i'm a coach
i
all right i actually just filled out my
retirement information
and i have a six percent uh match for my
company as well
don't do it so i am going to put 15 in
don't do it not yet not yet brother i
want you to attack that twenty thousand
dollars
get out of debt first yeah get out of
that first man i want you to
put all of your guns toward this 20 000.
okay if you're making 63 you can attack
that and be done with this debt bro in
about six to seven months
literally and if you really want to go
hard i would go drive for uber i'll go
drive for liv i'll go pick up something
else
and i'll have this debt knocked out in
four months you can't do it go because
i got five thousand dollars you could
put three thousand there towards your
paycheck
and get another two thousand dollars
better you'll be debt-free brother and
then after that
nick then after that now we're starting
to take advantage of what's coming up
which is your fully funded emergency
fund
but i love this oh i love this
let that six percent match just floating
up there let it haunt you
yeah get out of debt quick so you can
take that your your boss's other free
money
so good um
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
this is the ramsey show triple eight
eight two five five
two two five it's triple eight eight two
five five
two two five let's go to shane in dayton
ohio shane what's going on
not much how are you guys we're doing
great thanks for calling what's
up how can we help uh so
just a little backstory my parents are
divorced they have been for a while
um my mom has been in a relationship
for a long time off and on with a
married man
uh-oh um so
and obviously uh everything i was taught
and raised up
with you know that's it's immoral when i
don't you know
i don't support it okay um again this
you know those guys have been inaudible
for a while now i you know i see him
every once in a while again
i don't like being around that situation
so my question is is
how can i talk to my mom about
this and let her know my feelings on it
because
i feel like every time i do you know she
always gets defensive
or uh you know has every reason
as to why she should stay with him this
and that how old are you man
i am uh 23. 23. you still live at home
uh no sir i live with my wife okay
so you don't have a lot to say in this
conversation but
right i do respect your desire to have
to
to be heard right so what i would do
is anthony to go out to dinner i'd go
out to breakfast
right and i would go sit down and say
hey mom i
i don't i want you to know that i don't
like that you're in a relationship with
a married guy you raised me differently
than that
you gave me a set of values that i've
instilled in my soul
and this looks like you're not living
your own values
i love you you're my mom and you're a
grown woman you can do what you want to
um and you have to be prepared
prepared for thee and then she may say
bye then right and you've got to
decide for yourself how important this
conversation is what you're going to get
out of it what you're hoping to
accomplish with this conversation
and if you're going into it just so you
can make sure i was right i told her
what's
man that's a dangerous way to enter a
conversation because you've got to deal
with the back end and the fallout
if you think she can hear you if you
think she um
respects your opinion and you have the
ability to go in and have a respectful
conversation to
to your mother then um man i think
that's a great conversation i would have
that conversation with my parents but i
would do it very humbly and
knowing my place what do you think
anthony
you know i'm like 50 50 and i'll be
honest i think 50
of me agrees with you like yeah i would
want to tell my mom like hey mama uh
this is not cool you're hurting someone
else's family you're hurting
you don't know what's going on the other
side and you're a part
of that and i would definitely be scared
and nervous and then a part of me is
like
i'm married i have my own family
i need to worry about my family and not
create any more drama that can come into
my family
so part of me is like should i just mind
my own business
and the only and here's why i lean on
that side
if my mom was to bring him over my house
then it gives me permission
to now speak into it you know if if i
was to go over to the house with my wife
with my kids
and he's over there then that gives me
permission i'm not even saying something
to my mom i'm talking to
i'm talking to the married man you know
but it's like
you're the expert in this space i don't
think there's an expertise as much as
this is just what i would do in my house
shane are you worried about him coming
over to your house being around your
kids being around your young family
um what's the impetus for this
conversation
um it's more of just i want my mother to
be happy
um is this conversation gonna help her
be happy
i'll buy the secret it sounds like your
mama's
happy yeah so and she's happy in the
wrong way right
like i said they've been on and off for
i mean six years now and
let me ask you this question let me ask
you
is is he married as in living with his
wife or is he
married and separated not they even were
it's better
to say yeah no they are they are married
and still living with each other yeah
yeah yeah so maybe she knows about it
yeah
shane maybe try it this way maybe take
your mom out and say
it's been six years since the divorce
it's been six years you've been off and
on with this married guy
i just noticed you're not happy and i
love you you raised me with a different
set of
values than this it looks like you're
hurting it looks like you're struggling
looks like there's some guy in your life
that's taking advantage of you and i
love you as
as your son and now that i'm getting
older like
i just love you as as as my mom as a
friend
and um like what's going on your heart
tell me how i can help
maybe lean in towards it that way i do
think the boundaries conversation is
something that's going to come up sooner
rather than later
yeah right your wife um you and your
wife have kids and you decide i don't
want this guy around here
i think anthony's right i think the
harder more direct more integrous
conversation is
with him absolutely um that's a hard
conversation of course
and especially if he's 55 year old man
he's his he's not gonna want to listen
to a 22 year old
kid running his mouth at him and again
it's about respect and dignity at the
same time saying these are my boundaries
this is what where i'm drawing the line
in my house for my family
and i don't want you around and um
letting your mom know you're gonna have
that conversation but that's down the
road i think right now you
sound like you're you don't like what
your mom's doing but you're worried
about your
the state of your mom's heart and so i
think that starts that's a different
it's a direct but it's a different
conversation there
and anthony so i
part of me gets your
i don't want to create any more drama in
my family i got my own i'm working
through
heck yeah the other side of it is it
sounds like mom brought drama to
to the family she did right she did and
she's creating drama
in the other family sooner or later it's
going to come out
oh it is out the other woman knows right
yeah yeah
wait the other woman knows about his
mama yeah
oh my gosh yep see
that just couldn't be my mama man
because i i don't know if i can go with
my mom
in a very humble way my mom would be
upset with me
because she would hear the tone the
passion the fire in my
soul you know there's there's two
problems that i see here
one you're creating drama in another
family and two you're settling
for less than who you are right you
deserve
a husband you deserve a man that focuses
on you
you don't want a man to focus on you and
another woman so why put another woman
through that crap
and so you know that's why you're the
expert in this space because i would
probably respond
totally wrong and i'm gonna keep it i'm
gonna keep it a hundred
with our listeners uh because my mama
will my mama will probably smack me
uh my mom will probably tell me to leave
i'm gonna keep it 100 because
there's no way in the world i would tell
my mom i love you but i've lost so much
respect for
the fact that you you would bring this
kind of
drama and unnecessary drama into
our family and into another home
when you raise me so much better than
that so i it's so much
i don't think it's a professional
approach and i think for me it's
if if my mom is hurting for six years
still struggling wants connection
so badly that she's willing to
but you know what boundaries i want to
sit down and say hey something
something's
something's wrong in your heart man
exactly are you okay she's looking for
an
external fix to fix something internal
that's right and so it's like she's
looking for
but that's that's a relationship and
connection we're all looking for that
right absolutely but it's like
no fix it internal first because
internally she should know that she was
fearfully and wonderfully made
she should internally she should know
that hey i deserve
this and i'm settling for that right
and that is crap yeah you know i can't
cuss on this show
dave will come back and say you can no
longer be on this show but that's a
bunch of
bs you know and i just think that
um setting us up my emotions brother i'm
praying for you i'm praying for your
wife
i'm praying for the other family and i
just believe that god can shift some
things and so that that's that's the
best advice that i can give at this
present time
because i probably just made half of
america upset right now with me
no i think that here's the bigger lesson
for me
is we all have to have hard
conversations with people that we love
yeah and the best we can approach that
conversation with
you're fighting a war that i have no
idea about
versus i'm coming at you with my virtue
i'm coming at you to beat you up with my
right and wrong answers instead of
sitting down saying are you okay
i think we can solve a lot of problems
in this country if i sit down and say
brother sister how can i help yeah not
you screwed up you're wrong all right
it's good
it's way to i just love each other man
this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Music]
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the ramsey show
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom
window covering you get free samples
free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save
even more use promo code ramsey to get
the best deal
rules and restrictions apply today's
question comes from
bradley in wisconsin and bradley writes
last year my wife and i became involved
in a multi-level marketing business
since then i find i found out how
deceptive this company is in their
business practices
i don't want to waste any more money on
these products but my wife is so
brainwashed that i don't know if she
will exit this fake
dream it may come down to her choosing
this
business over me and our children
what should i do first thing brother
take a breath relax
there's way more going on here than
multi-level marketing
anthony you're speechless man
i i don't i don't know what to say here
bro um and here's why i
i don't i don't know i don't know too
much information to say i mean that's a
heavy statement to say that your wife
would choose this
this multi-level um marketing company uh
over you like i would need some more
information to see why does he feel that
way because i agree with you
if your wife is gonna choose an mlm over
you and your
children way bigger problems this is not
about the mlm
it's about something else that the mlm
is just covering
um and so uh i would suggest that this
guy gives your show a call
because you we need some more we need
some more questions
just with what we've got here bradley
what should you do
i don't even know i don't even like the
way you're talking about your wife what
you should do right now bradley is go
find someone to talk to
yeah i agree go find a professional to
talk to and say
i'm about to leave take my kids go to
war over my kids because my wife
wants to i don't know sell avon or
tupperware or whatever the mlm business
is
mary kay she wants to to do um
a stay-at-home business and i'm out and
i want to take our kids away there's
something way bigger going on here
bradley but you ever find yourself
up against a line here that says i'm
about to be out of here stop which
before you jump go
go talk to somebody yeah go talk to
somebody and for the listeners
i want to make super we're clear because
you named you named a couple we're not
calling those oh i'm just saying those
are scams no no no because i
i there are some solid mlm companies out
there that uh
that i think are good but there are
there are a lot of them out there that
are that are bad
and i've had the opportunity to speak at
some of them um
but um i do agree that some of them do
brainwash
do do mislead but then there are several
of them out there
that are good and if if you're willing
to put in the work and
good stuff for people yeah you can
really do it um you know i have family
that does
you know like avon and mary kay and so
um you know i respect him but then
there's some out there that lord jesus
i run from them i don't know enough
about them
yeah yeah i feel you i feel you now i
just want to make sure that we said that
because i don't want someone to think oh
he just said no no no no no i'm not
counting on anybody
i'm trying to morph look at get bradley
to look in the mirror yeah yeah
if you're gonna walk out on your family
over your wife's participation in a work
from home business
yeah there's something bigger going on
much bigger i
they need therapy they need help um and
and and correct me if i'm wrong john is
this even a conversation that they
should start by themselves or should
they literally go to counseling
and then walk through the the honesty
and the transparency
with a third party guiding them through
this journey or should they try it on
their own
so so this is a good breakdown for the
listener when i look at something like
this
and i see language like i found out how
deceptive
i don't want to waste she's going to
exit this fake dream
right he's angry yep he's angry
and the last thing a marriage or a
friendship
or a boss an employee they need is
someone to go try to have a relationship
conversation when they're pissed off
right yep so what i want him to do is go
sit with somebody
by himself by himself anger's good
anger is not a bad thing anger just
points you in the direction of something
you care about yeah it's good yeah right
yeah but when it changes your language
when it makes you get short of breath
when it makes you get ragey and ragi is
anger trapped right so when it makes you
start
wanting to start having fantasies about
grabbing your kids and getting out of
here
you need to go sit down with somebody
learn how to exhale
and then have a hard conversation with
with your wife you know that's that's so
good i mean
let's stay right there let's talk about
the importance of
therapy bro so i see a therapist
you know um doing what we do
um being on stages being on platforms
being
in front of uh the world as a public
figure
um i um there are some days that
that i get frustrated there are some
days that i i
um emotionally and mentally break down
there are some days that i feel like
just giving up i'm gonna be i'm gonna
keep it a stack
and i what you just said is i started
saying
certain words and immediately
uh one of my friends said you you're not
sick
but if you don't get help you will
become mentally sick
and i would definitely say and i'm
curious for your thoughts
because you promote mental uh mental
therapy and just seeing the therapist on
your show
when i started going to see a therapist
and i was 100
honest with the therapist i became a
better man
i thought better i thought clearer i
started owning some of my thought
processes
when someone offended me oh america let
me tell you the truth let me tell you
the truth
when someone offended me it wasn't that
they offended me
it's a it it was i was insecure about
something
and so my insecurity made what they said
offensive to me
to cover up the truth that i was
insecure about something
and so for me when i see a therapist now
man
uh she is walking me through the process
to okay wait why did this offend you
let's let's identify why did this offend
you
why did you feel this way and john the
truth is bro
incredible if i'm i'm i'm wrong and tell
me if you see this in your space
50 of the times when i'm hurt i'm
offended
was not because of the individual it was
because of something deep down inside of
me
that i that i need to resolve oh i think
i
appreciate your vulnerability there man
i think it's way higher than 50 percent
oh you think so way higher yeah because
at the end of the day
i give permission
to people to hurt me oh right
people can frustrate me dave can take
away my livelihood right he's my boss
his name's on my paycheck he can take
away my livelihood
right um the guy driving in front of me
can frustrate me
somebody on twitter or facebook can say
something that's egregious and
evil and wrong and it can make me mad
but i give permission
for somebody to hurt me and the smaller
i can make that group
the lighter i can walk through life the
less i walk through so
charged and fire up so i actually went
through an exercise back in grad school
where you pick who are you going to get
permission in your life to hurt you
and it should be about four or five
people and here's what happened
i love my parents yeah yeah i took them
out
i had this little imaginary box are you
serious so my dad is allowed to give me
advice
he's allowed to help me with things give
me his opinion
but he does i've don't give him
permission to hurt my feelings so good
but my wife she does and here's the
thing i told her what about your kids
absolutely not you know why cause
they're nine they're 11.
they're six if a six-year-old hey the
other day my six-year-old told me
uh she's yeah she's five she said hey
daddy
i love mommy more than you and i smiled
at her and said
i'm so glad you love mommy isn't she
great and then i started to walk away
and she realized she didn't get me she
goes
and i love hank my 11 year old son more
than you
and i said he is really remarkable young
man i'm glad you love him and then she
went for the jugular she said
and i love stella more than you that's
our dog
here's the thing i'm not gonna give my
hurt over to a child i've got a couple
of friends that have walked with me
for years and years i called him and
said you guys got permission use it
wisely
and they do and then i'm able to walk
through life
a little freer so good that makes sense
so good man
i get to choose who gets in there and
starts firing away
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
this is the ramsey show i'm john doloni
joined here by best-selling author and
ramsey personality anthony o'neil
taking your calls on life and money
let's go out to paul
in washington d.c paul what's going on
hey how you guys doing today good how
can we help ma'am
uh so i guess i'm a little bit lost in
the sauce here
uh so you know i at that point in my
life
in our relationship that uh i'm looking
for
an engagement ring i'm just not really
entirely sure how to
decide on a budget for it um you know
and i just want to say that like you
know that the
you know my my my lady is not the type
of person that
is going to be upset with anything that
i choose
but at the same time i want to be to be
excited about showing it off
and and i want to feel loved when she
gets it you know
that's such a good question paul let's
get some finances on you real quick
um uh howdy how are you paul
i'm 25. how does your fiance be
she is 25. okay cool we got 225 euros
two young
millennials on the low end side i love
it
um you have any debt right now
nope we just just paid decided to pay
everything off a couple weeks ago
and we say we so both of you are
debt-free
yep okay cool uh what's your um you have
anything in the uh savings account right
now
for an emergency fund uh i've got about
7k in cash 10k in crypto
uh 10k an investment
okay um what do you do for a living man
uh i'm in cyber okay okay what do you
make a year
uh about uh 115 base
115 base so what do you see on average
on a month base
like a monthly net wise
uh i get paid over two weeks so
probably just shy of just time six grand
6k okay cool great so here's the thing
man
um the general basis that dave teaches
um is one month of your salary all right
or whatever your average one month
salary that's a general basis whether
you're in debt or
or out of debt that's a general basis uh
now
is that law is that like hey you have to
do that don't go past it no um diamond
the diamond industry is is
is not it's it's kind of it's it's
interesting
uh but i would definitely sit down uh
look at a budget um 6k at your age is a
great
ring man i mean heck um
5k it is a great that's a that's a great
ring so i would say in your budget
keep it in between 4 and six thousand
dollars for your engagement ring
that that's what i would say because
what i want to make sure is that while
you're doing that you're also gonna cash
flow your wedding
okay so you're gonna need to set aside
at least i would say five to ten k for
that
um and then from there you all can save
up and grow from
grow as far as and get a bigger ring
down the road
a lot of people try to get very very big
and go buy this three
three uh carat diamond and like oh my
gosh and then now they're in debt for it
they're struggling on it but just
remember
and this is what i tell young people and
i'm not i'm not a relationship expert
i'm not a
a marriage expert but i am a money
expert
the bar that you set you got to go up
from there
so if you set it at 5k you can take that
thing back and get something that
seven to 10k but if you start off at 10k
you got to go up to 15k so if you set
the bar
at a level that is comfortable for you
and you know down the road
you can advance from there but i think
that's a good route so i think in
between four and six thousand dollars
and if you want to stretch it if you can
find a great ring for
you know 65 7k that's cool uh the key
thing is just don't go past what you
gross
a month all right
yeah yeah that sounds good i just didn't
want to fall into that
you know loop of three months salary
i know that much yeah i mean
and for what it's for what it's worth
paul that's 20k
bro hey it happens what every single day
if you spent twenty thousand dollars
on a ring call into the show triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you're in your twenties and you spent
twenty thousand dollars on a engagement
ring i want you to call into the show
and explain to us why
why you did it i want to know and paul
for whatever it's worth again i think
i'm
becoming the resident uh cheapskate
personality
i spent way less than that my marriage
has been fine
don't don't don't don't do your wife
like that it's been fine all right let's
go to liz in mobile alabama what's up
liz
hey so glad to um speak to y'all i'm
kind of hoping
you may have some kind of you know sage
wisdom for me or
you're talking to a couple of sages
here's what i can promise you the wisdom
the wisdom we will give you is free so
go for it what's up
appreciate it okay so um
i am recently a single mom i was
inspired by one of your previous callers
who mentioned
domestic violence um and that was our
situation
for almost 20 years as well
so recently living with my
children with a friend this is very
temporary
but having been a stay-at-home mom me
having my debt just
run up and my credit run through the
wringer having no job prospects
and no stable housing right now i'm just
i'm kind of
mind blown as to where to even start i
have
children in school um there's five of
them
from ages uh four to fifteen
um and i just don't even i'm looking at
my student debt i'd like to go back to
college but i also need to work
but i have very little in the bank very
little
coming in elsewhere in
way of child support i don't really
understand how that's been worked out
but it's it's dismal
uh so i just i just don't know which
point to kind of jump off of where where
do i
go what do i do first from from a
practical level because we're about to
come to the end of this show
i want to give you something very
practical to do and then i let john come
in
very quickly i think don't worry about
nothing else right now
um from a practical perspective find you
income okay that's the very first thing
is
find a stable income don't worry about
the debt don't worry about that don't
worry about this
find a job that will pay you stable
income
then from there give us a call back and
we can walk you
through okay here's how you start paying
off a debt
here's how you start building up a
savings account here's how you start
savings
but i think oftentimes when something
extreme like this happens in our life
we start focusing on everything well no
let's focus on one thing which is the
foundation
you need a job you need stable income
and then when you have that then we can
help but then on the mental side of this
john
with her facing all this what does she
do
so um this is an emergency liz
okay this is an emergency this is a
four-wall situation
right you've got to make sure that
you've got housing
that you've got food you've got
transportation and utilities and you got
your utilities
right so as anthony said you gotta
you're gonna have to hit the workforce
and you have to figure it out on the fly
you have to change the oil while the car
is driving down the highway
right so i want you to stay on the line
we're gonna give you a copy of our
friend ken coleman's best-selling book
proximity principal
to help you just even walk into that
door we're also going to give you a year
of ramsay plus and here's what ramsay
plus is going to give you it's a
step-by-step
plan on what you how you can start
managing your money but as anthony said
you gotta you gotta go get a job and
that sounds heartless and it sounds
crass
yeah there's not anything we can tell
you on the radio that's gonna heal
20 years of domestic violence you're
gonna have to get a group in your local
area you're gonna have to meet with some
women who have been through that same
thing and have overcome and there are
extraordinary
groups in almost every city united
states
it's gonna mean you're gonna have to be
vulnerable and reach out for help
and you've got some great friends high
five to your friends who are letting you
and your kids stay there while you get
your feet underneath you
but i want you to reach out to a group
of women in your community i want you to
reach out to folks who will help
women who are escaping domestic violence
in your local city there
in mobile i want you to focus hard on
what's next and you're not in a dream
job situation and what's the best me
situation you're on a
we got to get food so we can eat
situation all right and you're going to
start working there slowly but surely
we'll give you the tools that we've got
here but i want you to connect with the
local
mental health group there this is
another hour in the books thanks for
joining us
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from their dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money i'm john deloney joined
here by best-selling author
all-around good guy youtube sensation
anthony o'neil we're taking your calls
on your money
and your life triple eight eight two
five five
two two five it's triple eight eight two
five five
two two five anthony you got gas in your
car
man i uh now i do after looking around
for
two days what in the world
[Laughter]
it's been in gas is the new it sure is
man in tennessee like lord jesus i
pulled into five of them yesterday i'm
sorry we're out of gas i'm sorry out of
gas
i'm like all right go to the next one
had to go down in nashville where i live
we ran out of gas anthony america there
was no supply issues here in tennessee
no there was no uh missed deliveries
here in tennessee
none people lost their minds you ran out
of gas
we're out of gas it's all good though
that just means i can't come into the
office
[Laughter]
i don't know if i if i introduce you to
my boss name dave ramsey that's how he
rolls
hey man listen you run out of gas you
will walk to work hey dave sorry about
that brother i ain't walking
yes you would not say that let's go
outside
in boston massachusetts before we both
get fired what's going on abby how are
we doing
hey guys how you doing good how can we
help
yeah um i had a question about so i'm a
co
uh back on it so i'm a college student
at umass boston
and um i i i got on to the uh first baby
step i've saved a thousand dollars
and i put it into the bake out and i'm
new to the show i've been i started
listening to the for the show
in the past month he just i was driving
and he just came on on the radio and
it's like wow okay
that really it really touched when dave
was talking about
um how you know college and you know
like you know debt itself you know like
and
surprisingly um so umass boston is a
commuter student
like like commuter students go to umass
boston and um
if i live at home and um
i'm debt free okay cool so what's your
question man how can we help
so so so my question is
um how can i build wealth
so like i'm i'm doing i.t in like my i
haven't like i'm going for an i.t
program but
like a lot of people tell me that like
as
in in 19 industry you don't need to go
to college for it
so why are you in school um
so reason why i'm school is
they're like my parents i'm a first
generation um college student and
like my my parents have this you know
you either like
you have to go to school because like we
we came to america
you know for education and
for a better life sure
i i'm always of the face of the belief
that if you can pay for it
go to college it's awesome i love that
um
i am not always a fan of
kids living their parents dreams out for
them
but i also understand the international
experience is a much different unique
experience
but at the end of the day how can we
help you today
how are you are you asking how you can
invest and save money while you're still
in school
so my question is um so as a college
student
um i i i work um i
like i work but like i'm trying to like
i can't really
save because i like my my planning is
all like crazy um living at home
i'm trying to save more money and how
can i do that as a college student
yeah that's good man i think the simple
thing right now that you can do
abby is uh pretty much just stack just
stack all your money
here's the thing because i want you to
get through college 100
debt-free i know you said you are
debt-free now but i don't want you to
worry about building wealth
at this present time i want you to worry
about getting a
solid future uh with the solid present
so all of your money right now i just
want you to put it inside of a savings
account
because you never know two years going
into maybe your junior year something
may come up and what i don't want you to
do is have it invested
and it's locked away then now you gotta
you're gonna pull from it now you gotta
pay penalties
and also pay the interest uh not the
interest but pay penalties
so for me the number one tool that i'm
gonna tell you to do right now while
you're in college
it's just stack stack stack don't worry
about building wealth right now
don't worry about compound interest
right now i want you to go ahead and put
that money in savings account now listen
once you graduate college once you get a
good job
you're going to keep three months of
that inside of a savings account then
yes you're going to invest that stuff
into like a growth stop mutual fund
which is covered by roth ira uh you
should be around 21
22 around that time and then now we're
going to really focus on building wealth
because you're going to have some stable
income coming in
but one thing i do not want you to do is
be so
so gun hold on on getting money and
and building wealth that you miss out on
the opportunity to cover any
expenses that may come up during your
college experience
and so uh don't worry about investing it
right now man just put the money inside
the savings account
um cover it keep it saved up until you
graduate once you graduate then give us
a call back
i'll walk you through the steps on how
you can start investing that and
flipping that to where you can start
building wealth at a young age
going back to um a comment he made there
at the beginning
i think there's a lot of young people
whose
parents sit them down and say you're
going to be the one
you're going to be the one that gets out
of here we came here
for you you're going to be the first
and only kid out of this community out
of our family that gets out of here and
goes to college
and some in this situation if parents
have got money they can pay for it
but i've heard that over the years with
students when i've met with them when
they're two years in
and they're 50 000 in the hole and they
are either they're they're not making it
academically or they want to change
their major and it's going to be a whole
mess
and that message that dream was sold to
them and then you got to go take out a
bunch of loans for it
what do you tell that kid and you've had
this conversation a bunch of last few
years
that man it's got a whole family a whole
neighborhood backing them
saying you're going to be the one and
there's only one route to this
and it's through this the higher
education maze
and you're going to take out money
you're going to whatever you got to do
all all roads lead through college what
do you tell them
uh i mean i tell them once you once you
turn 18
it's time for you to man up you know a
woman up and have a respectful
um hard conversation with your parents
like hey thank you so much for loving me
i want to represent the family well but
also i don't want to be told
how to represent the family well it's my
life i want to be able to speak into my
own life and the direction that i want
to go and no matter what route that i
choose
mom dad grandparents guardian you all
should be
supportive of that and and give me
wisdom along that journey not put this
stamp
and only this stamp on it it's hard it's
not easy
uh but you gotta have it and parents
help your kid guide your kid don't force
your kids to do something
stay with us this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
you've been paying attention to the real
estate market this year
you've noticed that competition out
there is high
in part because available inventory has
been hitting all-time
lows anthony both you and i bought a
house this year
it's bananas now when inventory is low
it simply means there are more buyers
buying than sellers selling which turns
the pressure up
buyers want to snag the right house
sellers want to accept the right offer
this is not amateur hour low inventory
is here to stay to win in this market
you need a pro
by your side and that's why we find vet
and endorse
top real estate agents across the
country called endorsed
local providers to help you buy or sell
our agents have
years of industry success and refuse to
compromise your financial goals
no matter how tough the competition is
good news you can instantly connect with
an endorsed local provider
in your area today text house to 33789
and to find a ramsey trusted agent near
you
that's house to 33789
and whenever we do these pitches here's
the thing of course we got to make money
here
right but i also always want to
pipe in here we're not just trying to
sell you something that we don't do
i used an eop to buy my house anthony
used an eop
by your house we live this stuff that we
teach
yes and i can tell you my experience was
second to none
i was with you a few times when you were
back and forth to your agent
your agent killed it yeah and we're
going back and forth right now too over
some other stuff too you know
so my eop saving me money making me
money saving me money
and making me some more money so i mean
i i just want to encourage everyone
uh john and i we don't make a dime off
of you uh doing the eob no zero
so we really just want to help you um
save a dime um and if you're selling
your house
make more than a dime you know so
uh definitely check out our elps um
and uh and our real estate people and
they'll take good care of you my elp
helped me from going crazy anthony
because i had this
i thought this was how much a house is
going to cost i thought i'm going to get
over in this neighborhood
yeah man i was wrong on every
every count possible everyone absolutely
all right let's go to uh brooke in omaha
nebraska brooke what's going on
hi guys thanks for taking my call today
you bet what's up how's it going
going pretty well um i am newly engaged
i've been with my
fiance for four years now
congratulations and
you know right when we started dating we
kind of had talks about money and faith
and stuff
um i'm blessed enough that i'm not in
any debt
he is with student loans and stuff but
we got
started on that he agreed kind of like
dave talks about a knock down
fight about it but you know he opened up
and was receptive to it
same with faith he grew up in a house
that
you know didn't have any um religion or
talks of god and
he really wants to grow in that with me
and stuff so i'm just
wondering what i can do to help him on
those journeys because it's not like i
can help
pay off his debt right now since we're
not married and i don't have all the
answers for the fate stuff
so i just am a little at loss of what i
can do
man i appreciate your heart that's a
really that's an extraordinary approach
to taking somebody that you love and you
care about
with two sensitive topics like money
sensitive topics like religion
and saying how can i support somebody so
good for you high five to you
anthony i'd love to hear your thoughts
on that you know i
think you got to come into it uh from a
respectful and loving way and i hear it
in your heart that you love him
and i hear it in your heart that you are
respectful um i which is one thing that
i
which may be an unpopular opinion but
for me i would just ask him hey man
what's your vision
for your money you know what what's your
vision for
us if we're talking about marriage what
what what's your vision where are we
going
where do you see us financially in the
next five to ten years
and that would make him as a man step
back and be like yeah that's a good
question
you know what what it what are we doing
like what what are
what are our goals and you should and i
think by
asking him questions to make him think
rather than telling him how to think
i think is a better route when it comes
to a man
because men are prideful man men we
we we don't want to feel like we're
being attacked we don't want to feel
like we're in a corner
we don't want to feel like we're being
judged and we definitely want to feel
like our pride and our character has
been attacked
so if you just ask him a simple question
and i could be off on this one uh
here uh dr john but i think for me
um any time my if i was engaged
i would hope that my fiance would ask me
questions to make me
think and then my answers would
personally convict me
right and then that's a better way to
get me to see
um especially as my fiance because then
now i would feel the weight that i need
to change
i need to make some changes so that way
my
choices my financial decisions are not
impacting my future wife my future
family
and so that's one thing that i would do
uh brooke is
just ask him like hey what are your
financial goals with the fam
family you know do will we be able to
buy a house one day like
where do you see us financially um and
can we have a conversation about that
yeah i had a similar thought here which
was
you can't solve these problems for him
but you can be with him
yeah you can walk alongside him as he
wrestles with them
and anthony i think it's it's an
important thing to point out there is so
much shame around money
yeah in our culture we have man
i'll say this and i say it over and over
again the the
the answer to the question what are you
worth is never a dollar amount
right but we have distilled that down in
this culture to all the vacations you
didn't go on the degrees you got or
didn't get or where you worked and when
you did
what are you worth as a number yeah and
so you take somebody
who's meet somebody wonderful like
brooke who's got no debt
who's got a a stable family and they
look and say man i've made some choices
some financial choices that have left me
with debt that might saddle my new
wife with that you instantly go to shame
i screwed up i'm an idiot i'm i'm i'm
and anthony the amount of
energy i spend in my life
holding a pen trying to go back and edit
something that's already happened there
is a period at the end of that sentence
this guy borrowed money period you
cannot edit that right the world is
waiting for you to write that next
sentence
what are you going to do now right and
so brooke i think the
first gift you can give him around money
is not beating him up for it letting him
walk through it he's gonna feel
embarrassed by what he did the more he
reads
and you can be his greatest cheerleader
his greatest supporter
and then the same as you get into man
you want to cut down religious
people been fighting over this stuff
having conversations for
millennia right but you can walk
alongside him as he asks hard questions
as he leans into hard conversations does
he ask you your opinion has it lived out
why they do this how does this thing
work
at the end of the day it goes back to
being with him yeah right how much debt
does he have brooke
yeah um 47 000
okay okay uh what's your biggest fear
right now with them i'm curious
i mean it sounds
dumb but you know we get married and die
and then you know we don't end up in
heaven together that type of thing
and and i'm just asking the question
uh do you think it's because he's in
debt that you know
um well no or because of his faith
no no um yeah just because you know
he didn't grow up accepting jesus and
stuff like i did and i know it's
something that he wants to grow in
okay but i just don't know how to help
him get there
i think it's a good moment to go sit
down with some wise counsel yeah some
people that you trust in your life that
you allow to speak into your life yeah
and allow him to go ask all the hard
questions and the easy questions and
then come back and doubt and be angry
and frustrated all those things are part
of a natural part of that journey man
and i would definitely say this bro
don't don't don't carry all this weight
on you
right you know be a good fiance
love him but put all the weight on god
pray ask god to step in and fight those
battles but i love your heart queen
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
have you been dreaming about starting
a business or maybe you have a business
and you want to take it to the next
level no matter what stage you're at
it's time to make
money doing what you love and the
business boutique
conference will help you make it happen
on october 14th through the 16th
rockstar speakers including dave ramsey
christy wright anthony o'neal jasmine
starr
nora jones bianca olaf and others will
cover
topics including social media branding
goal setting accounting and more running
a business can be overwhelming
but it doesn't have to be get the
inspiration and the practical steps you
need to chase your version
of success join us for this three day
event in person in nashville or you can
attend via live stream
early bird passes for the business
boutique conference are on sale now
text boutique to 33789
that's boutique b-o-u-t-i-q-u-e
to three three seven eight nine
and anthony christie wright sits between
you and i right in her office in our
office complex up there
i tell you what somebody's gonna bring
it
christy wright ah she brings it every
time christy wright
is the guru of helping ladies turn their
hobbies into
profit um i just had her on my show
and she completely killed
uh i'm honored to be speaking this year
and i'm telling you right now
this lineup is amazing uh the wisdom and
the knowledge
uh and the information that uh business
boutique and christy wright that will be
giving
is amazing and here's the truth man you
know the rising entrepreneur is a woman
it's not a man it's a woman and so
um you sound surprised i'm not surprised
i'm not surprised
you know i'm i'm really not surprised uh
and if you really do the research
research the number one
rising entrepreneur is a minority woman
and so
i want to suggest to any woman
in this space even if you don't have an
idea but you know you want to be an
entrepreneur
you need to get to nashville tennessee
and be a part of this uh business
boutique
um situation because i'm telling you
right now chrissy wright has some
information that is fire
aka which that is good um dave is going
to be speaking uh my good friend nona
nona jones
she works with facebook oh my gosh
her information is going to be electric
and then i'm going to tell you right now
ladies
what i'm going to be talking about
you're going to want to be there so
listen
uh join us um for christy wright's um
premier event business boutique
uh i promise you you believe um on fire
you will leave with the with the
information that you need to start
natural tools yeah you know and this is
not just one of those conferences you
show up to
um and just get a bunch of fluff and get
all excited and you don't know what to
do
um i i've i've been to several of
chrissy's events just to see what is she
giving
because i'm very critical on what we do
as as ramsay solutions
um it can't just be a good event it has
to be a life
transformation event and this event is
one of those events that
will transform your life with some
amazing speakers but also the amazing
community of ladies
that are in the building so i'm looking
forward to it that was just a not an
extra plug but just to really
give christy her praise and her props uh
for
strategically making sure she has the
right people on stage
that will bless uh the ladies um in the
building
uh she's met with me uh you know several
times like hey what are you saying what
are you thinking
okay we change this because this is the
felt need
like christy is not just saying hey come
speak and do it no
she's guiding everyone including dave
you know like hey
this is what we need this is what we
need to be saying
because i want to make sure that
everyone who's watching us
on live stream who walks into the
building can
walk away and go change their life
so what i love about working here this
weekend we'll we'll head to dallas for
the entree summit yeah and you know
there's just a lineup of rockstar
speakers similar to this
and what's cool is you see a bunch of
folks who
you know me you christy rachel you see
these
folks who do this for a living yeah but
you see them in the back of these rooms
these auditoriums with pins and a pad
taking notes
right because you get to watch it happen
i was already planning on going to watch
this
this event because the lineup is great
and now that i know that you're on it
i can't wait to see what you're going to
say to this people man it's going to be
fine i can't wait
i mean the the content is going to be
great and
i don't want to take up too much time
because i i i just want the world to
know like yo this
what christie writing what business
boutique is doing uh
it's a good gift like like husbands
boyfriends you know if if your
wife or if your girlfriend has always
been saying hey i'm thinking about
starting a business i would love to
i have this idea yo this will be the
best
gift um birthday gift anniversary gift
um or boyfriends just because gift
hey i want to sow into your future
here's a gift
um here's a ticket to get to nashville
tennessee to go to business boutique
and go get something um i guarantee you
boyfriend you may be the husband sooner
than you
you think if you just get this ticket to
business boutique all right before we
get
canceled out here let's go to jp in san
antonio what's up jp how are we doing
good how can we help ma'am thanks for
taking my call hey listen i just want to
let this guy go real quick and see what
advice i can get yeah
hey talk directly to the phone jp
is this better there you go all right
sorry about that um lost my job
last march due to covid uh so i got laid
off from
a job that was paying me 40 an hour um
after going through the whole year i got
another job
that's i'm only making 14 an hour
i've had to sustain myself through my
jump into my savings that i had while i
had my
previous job um i paid off a lot of my
debt i had
um which i don't regret i think now in
hindsight i probably would have done
something a little bit different
but i don't regret paying off the debt
i've paid but i've had to jump into my
savings
pretty much almost you know during that
house
uh we're probably with a couple of
thousand dollars left in there um
i am struggling to get back on track and
trying to see what i need to do uh see
what you guys have in mind
in regards to building that up what i've
done so far
has been obviously cut out
a lot of things unnecessary spending
that i was used to when i was working my
previous job um you know now it's
reaching out to you all to see what what
um
where i need to go what do i need to do
cool great you know jp uh
definitely we want to um apologize for
your loss of of your job
especially man that that's uh
you along with you know millions of
other people uh we we
are definitely understanding and we're
definitely prayerful and believing that
things will turn around
um you know this is it it's it's a
it's an easy answer but it's a hard
answer jp um
and the reason why is because you know i
just be transparent
we have a shovel problem we have an
income problem you went from making
forty dollars an hour to fourteen
dollars an hour
um and so your lifestyle uh changed a
little bit but probably the majority of
your expenses didn't change that's
that much so i can understand why you
are struggling
so right now what we have to do is
figure out how do we get you back to at
least 30
an hour uh because you went down not
just half
you went down close to 70 percent and so
right now what can we do and you can
speak into
this on how how to get you
back to at least 30 an hour
to a good situation to where you can get
back into income
um i can suggest second jobs i can
suggest
maybe re um not relocating but possibly
relocating to find a job that can give
you 40
an hour but texas as far as in real
estate right now and the cost of real
estate
to live is is much cheaper probably than
a lot of different states so
right now i would definitely say you got
to get a different job or extra job
hey jp hang on the line here because i
want to dig into this a little bit when
we get back
um
it doesn't smell right to me anthony i'm
going to dig in and see what what jp's
been up to for let's do it here
all right hang with us this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture is jeremiah 1 19.
they will fight against you but will not
overcome you
for i am with you and will rescue you
declares the lord
ross simmons says hustle beats talent
when talent doesn't hustle all you fancy
pants is out there listen to that again
hustle beats talent when talent doesn't
hustle
talent plus hustle is unstoppable i love
it
all right let's go back to jp in san
antonio texas
all right jp so to recap here you were
making 40 bucks an hour
cruising through life coveted hit you in
the mouth
there in san antonio you lose your job
heartbreaking man and over the last year
you've been making 14 bucks an hour what
do you do for a living
uh from my last job i was in the oil
field okay and what do you what have you
been doing to
duct tape things together over the past
year uh
recently i've attended job now it's been
in private security
okay so do you mind if i poke at you a
little bit
yeah go for it what have you going from
40 bucks an hour to 14 bucks an hour
what has kept you from scrambling to
pick up a second in the third and a
fourth and a fifth job over the last
year
instead of just uh part of it has to do
with uh custody
okay tell me about that arrangement um
with our our son okay so uh just
you know trying to hold my end there uh
when i was gone
with my previous job i was going a whole
week and
came back for for a whole week so that
worked out there so i've had to
kind of rearrange my schedule um you
know i've done a lot
out by by the lord's favor i was able to
continue to maintain
uh my apartment you know with um that i
used to be in i had to cancel that at
the end of my term
knowing i was not going to be able to
pay for that apartment anymore
um so i've had to obviously downgrade
and uh
make changes in that area but um
that's my custody arrangement has has
really kept me from having to but not
having but but
being able to get another job okay
i want i want you to recognize here and
i'm gonna tell you something that's
that's not cool and people in your life
probably aren't
telling you but your body experiences
job loss as trauma
that loss of dignity that loss of
control that loss of provision
that's a big deal that registers in your
body
losing your housing your body registers
as a trauma
so while you're scraping and clawing and
man i applaud you dude you're trying to
be a good dad you're trying to make ends
meet
i want you to recognize that your body's
taking it on the chin
and there's something important about
acknowledging that letting people in
your life know hey it's been a hard year
and from that ash that's where you rise
brother
okay so here's the question what do you
want to do
i want to get back out to uh the field
where i was
you know that's that's where my passion
is and
that's why i love doing it i didn't
think i would love doing that job as
much as i did and
and i i miss it i've been missing it i
still talk to
some of my buddies that were fortunate
to not
be laid off when we got laid off 70
percent of our
of our workers from our company were
laid off so
those that stayed on we're fortunate
they're obviously tenured but
i miss it i have the bug and that's why
i want to that's where i want to go is
get back out there
so are you on the horn every week
looking for
all you know all the way from odessa to
el paso to
eastern new mexico to midland are you on
the phone there trying to get on any
crew possible doing whatever you can to
get back out there
i have been um you know obviously
through the past
with the exception of the past two
months um it was hard nobody was hiring
yep uh for the past couple of months
they've picked up a lot of the companies
right now are
taking back the guys that they laid off
um
and doing it in that in that reverse
order yeah so the company have
the company i was with they're doing the
same thing but um i have spoken to them
you know they said that they're going to
see what else they had because that's
what i was based out of was
out of west texas in new mexico yeah
yeah so um so here's the deal i got to
get back out there
you are anthony referred to it in the
first uh in the last segment
you're in an emergency situation you're
hemorrhaging money
you're running out right you're burning
through your savings you're having to
um move you're at
yeah 30 of your earning which you were
this time last year
this may be one of those moments where
you sit down with your wife you sit down
i mean with your ex-wife and you say i
need to go all in for six months
would you be willing to work with me on
a custody arrangement for a limited time
so that i can build back up i got to go
earn some money and is that what anybody
wants
no is it it's not but you're finding
yourself in a situation
that you're if your dream gig out
in the fields isn't open it hurts but
you gotta go find something else what
can you control
right if you want to spend every other
week with your kid
if you want to spend this 50 percent
time man i so respect that
i hope every dad in that situation is
all in
and brother you got to go earn a living
right you got to put some money
in the account so that means you're
gonna have to have some hard realization
real conversations with yourself
hard ones right and i know you've
thought about it and you've wrestled
with it and you haven't slept at night
and all that
it's time to start putting your feet on
the gas pedal and hit it brother
right you got to go get that other job
anthony am i on the right track no
you're you're on the right track brother
i like what you said man
i i totally agree nate uh let's listen
to him
all right jp get after it brother get
after it and we're rooting for you man
let's go to nate and akron ohio nate
what's up
hey how are you guys doing good how are
you
great i was just doing um i'm 21 right
now
and i was just wondering i know you guys
suggest that 15
into your 401k um i just i don't own a
house or anything at the moment right
um and i was just wondering if you
suggest i do a little more than that a
little less than that you know
if just if there is any tweaking of that
if you don't own a home or
you know paying a mortgage on a home
yeah man uh how much are you making a
year right now
uh nate uh i make about 35 000
a year and i actually just got a
promotion yesterday so i should be
making closer to 40 plus
cool how much money do you have in your
savings right now
i have about twenty thousand dollars
that's what i'm talking about nate
come on young man that's what i'm
talking about let's get this money
and you have no debt right yeah i i know
i have absolutely no debt okay cool yeah
so man just keep sticking with the 15
um anything extra that you uh you have
left over that you think you want to
invest
here's how you invest it set it aside
save it up so you can put it towards the
house one day
um i think that's the that's the next
best thing for me is go ahead and get
into real estate get into home ownership
you know um so that's what i would
definitely suggest for you
uh but uh 15 to your 401k are they
matching it
um they match up to six
yes okay cool here's what i want you to
do i want you to get on uh go to
daveramsey.com and get connected one of
our smart investor pros
because what i want them to do is look
at your 401k
uh is it a roth or is it a traditional
it's a traditional employee or an
employer
it's an employer okay cool so great so
you're not going to put all 15 percent
into the traditional what i want you to
do is go ahead and put six
percent into your traditional uh because
they're matching it all right so
the secret here is match will beat a
roth roth would beat a traditional so
with that being said you got a match
you're going to get input six percent in
then you're going to take that over and
get one of our smart investor pros
and go open up a roth ira and put the
rest of your money into that
so that way you can go ahead and get
that free interest growing
when it comes to compound interest so i
would not put all 15 percent inside of
your
traditional 401k i would put up to the
match of six percent
then i would slide over to a smart
vessel pro go to daveramsey.com or just
type in smartvestedpro.com
and get one of our smartbester pros and
tell them hey i want it i want to invest
the rest man but
such a great question from this young
man 20k in his account
yeah that's a great example for every 21
year old out there across the country
well anthony thank you so much great
show thank you like to thank our
producers
ben hill and the associate producer
kelly daniel
for another great ramsay show
congratulations on your nine-year ramsey
anniversary kelly
america treat each other with dignity
treat each other with respect
have a great weekend this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you